hey everyone ant-man in the wasp at a
new trailer come out this week showing
off this equals fun visual effects but
only the slightest tense at the movies
villains and story so we're gonna break
down where we think this plot of this
movie's gonna go based on clues that we
found in the trailer and of course for a
deeper Easter egg breakdown check out
the other video we released earlier this
week but for now welcome to new
rockstars news or a deep dive in all the
biggest story this week so we're also
gonna talk about Black Panther and the
whole Marvel vs. DC war that never ends
roads are gonna discuss a few other
miscible details from the ant-man
trailer that we missed the first time
around we're gonna talk about some other
stuff but I am Erik Bosse and these are
my best friends whom I believe only
exist in my imagination correct one is
your old pal Sam sure I'm Phillip milena
I'm the COO bing-bong was based off of
hopefully you guys can see him too so
let's get started with our top story the
new ant-man in the wasp trailer now most
of the footage seems focused on the wasp
and her abilities along with a you know
some great visual effects of a building
turning into luggage but not a whole lot
of details as to what the actual story
of the movie is going to be but we do
know that Scott Lang will be under some
kind of house arrest following his kind
of treason and Captain America Civil War
but obviously that's not gonna last long
the trailer did include a few other plot
related clue so let's discuss three
components of the ant-man and the wasp
plot as we know it as of this moment
okay first the villains the trailer
briefly showed us two of them first
there's ghosts ghosts as a villain for
the Marvel Comics who can become
invisible or intangible and pass through
surfaces and they can take over
electronic devices ghosts work for Tony
Stark's corporate rivals here ghost is
being played by Hannah John Cayman it's
cool change and usually it's a bummer
that she won't go up against Iron Man
because like because she's like
anti-capitalist it's like a like you get
I get cool anarchy hmm vibe but it could
work with Hank Pym too he owns a company
it's just nothing cool you know the same
way that arrow repurposed a lot of
Batman villains and stuff like I think
some
bro galleries are a little better and
like ant-man ant-man's villain was a
good guy it was they just repurposed a
different good guy so to borrow ghosts I
think is actually a kool move especially
because it's related to his powers you
know the not the idea of going subatomic
but Divya what's a club when you can
phase-shift yeah quantum they could deal
with the quantum realm so when he gets
like quantum vibrations yeah I think
that's very cool though I think that's
like a good match in capabilities
without being the exact same thing which
is one of the only ways that people ever
have ideas for villains it's the same
thing but bad like think about Iron
Man's like well no this is different but
can achieve the same yeah it sounds like
from the little we were able to gather
from the shots that they might be
retconning ghosts origin story to be
somewhat similar to like the Pym
industries and and the same stuff that
created a man created ghosts in this
case but maybe the technology went awry
or the Pym particles didn't work
properly and then had a different side
effect like synthetic ones like they and
you got a tease I think they cut the
scene but in the first ant-man some
Hydra people like stole some of the Pym
particles so maybe something went wrong
or like whole like you there's a shot of
her hand like like freaking out I kind
of like phasing all over the place
there's gonna be really cool I like that
I hope they focus on that and don't also
add hacking abilities to it because the
character can also do as you would
cyborg like any phrase with any
electronics and hack them by touching
them and it's kind of like well that
doesn't make sense just ox cables into
computers it doesn't work it makes a
little less sense of just like the
typical hacking in movies which is just
like fwq you know I mean yeah well
there's also another villain who showed
up sunny birch he's played by walton
goggins it's like an awesome character
actor birch was a corporate villain and
weapons developer in the comics he's a
colleague of a dye stain and in the
trailer you can see him briefly in a car
and then he shows up in a ferry later
and both of them
with him and ghosts seem to be in
pursuit of Scott Lang hope Van Dyne
trying to get their hands on their Pym
technology I think it's safe to assume
that a big part of this movie will be
dealing with ant-man's giant
contribution of at the Civil War love
war vent going viral in public and now
this pimp technology seems to be a
target of other more evil interests oh
yeah we caught that pun a giant
contribution it's more subtle we caught
it yeah really quick this is Iron Man 2
100%
I first ant-man like most Marvel origin
stories are Iron Man but we hijack or
Iron Man but spoiler me on but now it's
it's I it was Iron Man put small and now
it's remember when you had an evil
whiplash II like it's like Iron Man put
a little different it's like be a ghost
and then you get evil corporate man
which is Sam Rockwell playing Justin
Hammer is like no no no it's Walton
dragons who always in my mind but they
definitely take Iron Man's format and
they repeat it a lot but the part that
they don't repeat and I wish they would
is is why I think the whole Marvel
Universe worked is if you go back and
you watch Iron Man 1 it's actually one
of the only films in the whole Marvel
lineup that is such a strong character
study the I mean the entire first like
half of that movie is like Tony Stark
gonna cave that's because they go so
into building this character that ends
up having an old Marvel Universe on his
back but they were able to do that
because they went to such a deep dive in
the character I don't think that they
repeat that part of it enough no they
don't they in a different way they do
that for Captain America with like
Winter Soldier it just a different
format which is fine that's what you're
supposed to do that way we cared about
the character finally but yeah I totally
that's kind of the Hollywood model of
like taking what they see working on the
surface without wanting to repeat the
work that went into it's not easy to
make a movie where a characters look at
looked at in depth and there's a lot of
character development it's really hard
for a screenwriter to do because you
have to put your character in a cave for
like a half hour but it ends up getting
this like this great place where we all
end up loving Robert Downey jr. in this
role I don't know but I don't know if
it's specific to Iron Man this is kind
of kind of what we saw in the Dark
Knight right like the first movie
introduces a character in the world the
second movie shows the consequences of
what would the world look like if that
person
were a public figure and what kind of
copycats would he inspire and I like it
too because of it being now revealed
that this technology exists it's a
little different from Iron Man where he
it was more public this is like this is
serious
this is very serious like it if people
were to actually get their hands on this
things could go bad very very quickly
and I think ghost is probably gonna be
an example of that like know physically
like someone could be seriously messed
up also to improve upon like it is like
Iron Man too but I meant to you barely
got anything happening the suits you got
war machine and then nothing after that
like I've been doing the rewatch of
things so you can see my Iron Man to
break down but in this it's like Peyton
Reed is having as much fun as possible
with the shrinking tech and that makes
me so happy they have so many good gags
in this yeah well let's talk about the
quantum realm right shall we traffic
gamers really attack now this is of
course the subatomic dimension that
Scott slipped into when shrinking down
in the first ant-man it's also where
Hank PIMs wife Janet Van Dyne that's
hopes mother disappeared into in that
flashback in the 80s when they were
disarming the missile michelle pfeiffer
will be playing janet in this movie and
while she didn't show up in this trailer
the sequel will definitely show the team
returning to the quantum realm where
they will try to find Janet that much
has been confirmed by several members of
the cast that's not something they're
trying to hide we are gonna see the
quantum realm again in the more you like
a tease of it sorry I didn't mean to
step on that but you got teased of it in
the trailer right well we do see a I'm a
bit subatomic but it is a microscopic
seemingly microscopic view of the those
little water bears are degrades which
are not totally microscopic you can't
see them with the naked eye cup but that
you can get a clear look at them with a
microscope but that's not which re
watching that clip from ant-man it's not
just subatomic it like goes on the
surface of like a nucleus of an atom and
just goes deeper like four or five
layers deeper beyond that it's a really
cool part that thing I would be super
excited to see it again which we are now
in the Marvel Comics the quantum realm
is referred to as the Microverse
it's actually a separate universe that
contains entire worlds that like the
star system sub atomic a' at one point
dr. doom gets trapped in the mike
and Congress a planet and he shrinks
down the Fantastic Four but they end up
getting rescued by ant-man so what do
you guys think we'll see entire planets
and societies in the quantum realm that
might be just one too many things to
happen they did that I do think that
there is something very interesting
today it's kind of like I was gonna
compare it to a DC story but it's
actually more fun to compare it to a
Rick and Morty story yeah like reverse
reverse the concept of how do you
survive in this thing and then do you
end up if there is other living stuff do
you end up interacting with it and then
ruling over a potential various things I
think it'd be an interesting thing to
explore but realistically we got about
90 minutes yeah well that's the thing
looking at this trailer was only like a
minute 40 seconds and it all seemed to
be showing pieces of like one morning
right like there was like a chase
sequence it was you see like Scott and
his house and there's like a couple
scenes that where the wasp is fighting
people in a kitchen but like I feel like
that could all be from the first act to
the movie and yeah I want to see you
just deal with the weird people in
subatomic Oh for the rest of the movie
that's just me I think it'll be a little
bit closer to the concept the quantum
realm you could equate it to maybe the
afterlife and it's the idea of going and
getting her dead mom back and of course
you could set a whole movie in the
afterlife like what dreams may come or
something right oh yeah really
interesting that's just a very different
movie instead I think it's a little more
the story
Osiris that goes down into hell Orpheus
Orpheus all right and and brings back
what Cyrus is a Egyptian one so he's
really just that idea of like having to
descent into the afterlife to bring
someone back yeah it's definitely gonna
be a part of this I just don't think
it's gonna be the full plot you could
also get because they mentioned you're
like sure introduction or a multi
version and Doctor Strange is gonna
explain it more but then this could just
be like once they get that small and you
could get like magic elements you could
see some of like the mechanics of how
that works because it doesn't that that
sentence that I just said makes zero
sense like what that means exactly no
it's just confusing the same idea of
paranormal activity not the movie but
the literally paranormal activity
things that we refer to as magic at a
certain point is it science that we just
don't get yet what's that is that a
phrase it's spooky something at a
distance spooky action it's what you
could get some fun stuff but what I
meant by that is that you could get like
glimpses of the multiverse and I could
see like other realities once you like
that far down yeah well I feel like the
the quantum realm is really the only way
to link ant-man into this like cosmic
event that they're about to have with
infinity work it's other than otherwise
I was down there yeah you know some of
you suggested when our trailer breakdown
we in the comments you guys were saying
that maybe that's one way jokingly and
they shrink down inside Thanos his mouth
or something and then like expand like
the one where he gets tiny squirrel
stealing I said here he's tired of
paying two dollars a slide yeah all
right well the third story detail is
Laurence Fishburne's character Bill
Foster whom we saw briefly briefly in
the trailer and the comics Foster is
known as Goliath
well again the comics Goliath is a
superhero in his own right
in the Civil War comic series brief
spoiler alert for this comic or not it's
a poor comic that came out ten years ago
Goliath dies a super tragic death which
is a huge emotional impact on all the
characters especially Tony Stark who was
the one who built the Thor clone that
killed him may I may he gets his chest
blown out by evil robots or it is oh it
is so it's Mark Millar and he's the guy
who wrote like Ultimate Comics which is
like what if ventures were depressing
and then you read this it's like
oh yeah the craziest best thing about it
is that it whole is something that
comics don't often do but I love when
they do is hold on to the real-world
logic so he's in essentially he's the
equivalent of giant man in civil war the
movie he's like that size except gets
killed in a similar way to the moment of
war machine going down like it has the
same emotion but the thing that happens
is now there's a giant body that's just
left out on the battlefield that they're
like how do we even bury this thing yeah
so his body stays out there for a long
time and it becomes this whole like
tragic thing this family has to go see
because he can't shrink back down he's
dead if the barium decides at that size
by the way like this moot that wouldn't
work in this movie since we invented a
thing that just makes anything big or so
you gonna start just like disco at him
ask you as you're about to put him in a
small hole you just like you throw a
little thing his body shrinks really
fast like inside a flower or a handful
of dirt you just throw portables well
it's not totally clear of this movie
version of Bill Foster will even be
Goliath he probably will be may be that
hero mantle is just something that's
will be from like his past that he like
gave up a long time ago but we'll see I
don't know I mean do you guys see
Goliath as the hero come becoming part
of the MCU I've got a pitch for what I
think could happen and what I would love
to happen very similar to the way
Watchmen plays out Watchmen is about two
generations of heroes
the current heroes that we know well but
then that there were some you know in
the 60s or whatever and I feel like
they've already established that a
little bit with Hank Pym and you
remember how it starts with that John
flattery Howard Stark flashback scenes
oh yeah and the previous one I think in
that time period with Janet Van Dyne so
that they could all have been you know
not quite an Avengers equivalent but
there were a force of heroes and so this
kind of establishes to me I would
imagine that they need the people from
that time including Janet for some
reason something from that time has come
back and now has consequences and so it
would link in why he's kind of old brown
but also maybe fingers crossed a little
bit of an incredible thing we're it's
like
they still fit right yeah yeah oh yeah
but I think it'd be cool and you could
get um not to bring it back but it the
first story that came to my head was
he's also was a part of shield and he
helped Hank in a way with the ant-man
suit and he got as soon as Hank got
booted he did too and he's like he lost
his job so what is he supposed to do so
he gets a little jaded and he starts to
experiment with trying to recreate Pym
particles maybe he didn't create it but
he was able to manage it with Hank and
that's he accidentally makes ghosts and
so he ends up having little team up with
Hank and Janet as a way of trying to
like hey ghost is gonna go like nuclear
or something like she's freaking out we
don't know how to stop her she's using
the technology in a bad way there's some
there's some fun stories there I'd like
him to be a good guy to also like to see
him be de-aged the way that Michael
Michael Douglas is good but cuz it looks
so good I would like to see young Larry
Fishburne how about young Michelle
Pfeiffer like Batman Returns so cool
yeah well I yeah it you mentioned
Watchmen it kind of was what really
helped the force awakens is seeing this
old generation with the younger
generation mixing and they they were
able to bring some of that ethos to the
story that way I like that in the first
ant-man I would be cool to see that in
this one I mean the difference is with
the force awakens we all like knew those
icons everyone's favorite up there neo
save one of the world you know one of my
favorite diehards you can come at me
about this is diehard 3 with Sam Jackson
it's a good end and it's because of the
idea of like a guy who's like I don't
really want to do this action movie and
I feel like you get that a little bit
when you have older characters that get
to come in it's like oh no thank you and
then they're forced to like fight
alongside I love that so even if we
don't know the characters well just
imagine Paul Rudd clashing with like the
older generation of heroes in the way
they do things I think also hit just the
side things Scott's daughter aged up a
lot like I just forgot in my head I know
she wasn't in like an infant like I but
she was so young and now she's aging up
I'm I'd be kind of king of disease but
if it'd be cool they stuck with her for
a little bit and like waited on on a
third movie that way she could maybe be
Kassie laying the superhero yeah yeah or
like a teenage hero which would be kind
of a fun elements and spider-man's
younger you gotta get a younger girl
we're mapping this franchise over the
Honey I Shrunk the Kids
let us know what past movie you want
this movie to be but yeah yeah we're
gonna return to ant-man and other things
that we missed but we'll see more as we
learn more about this movie and we'll
continue to do deep dives in all of it
but let's move on to this week's trivia
question and it looks like they are
going to be keeping things ant-man
themed funny how that tends to be the
pattern right where our lead topic ends
up also being the same topic as our
trivia question
[Laughter]
so our trick question is in the first
ant-man what was the name of the Pym
technologies executive whom Darren cross
disgustingly murdered are turning into a
tiny splat of goo I guess this is the
guy who is like challenging cross o
cross tried to shrink him with that
faulty tech and then and splattered him
into that gunk and then he like wiped
him up and flushed him it was yeah that
was what I remember it was cool I
thought was horrifying I think it's
still like the most horrifying that in
the MCU from what I can remember and I
don't know how like I think I know we're
supposed to see him as a villain but
it's like I his death or whatever
happened across at the end of that movie
was not enough for what he did that poor
Noble executive who just didn't trust
its technology long hands and tried to
speak up about it
it was super controversial to remember
that that it was like this is supposed
to be a like like the funny one because
there hadn't really been a phone and
then he just good this guy was crazy I
really like I mean I I enjoyed it cuz I
was like oh Darren cross isn't like
redeemable really in any way he just
went crazy
it's gooping people I keep thinking of
Darren Criss every time we said yeah
Teenage Dream like I'm referencing
Darren Criss and Glee and because Dave
Davis otherwise no one would really
so we get the answer to that yeah we'll
get it later in the show or judges we'll
figure out who won and then the winner
will get to do our goodbyes the loser
will have to do some funny stuff during
our in other news headlines etc etc you
guys know how this works but let's we're
gonna come back to ant-man again later
this episode but for now let's move on
black panther will be coming out in a
couple weeks guys
and while ticket sales are breaking
records the movie might be getting
caught in a bit of crossfire at of the
eternal Marvel vs. DC war a Facebook
event titled give Black Panther a rotten
an audience score on Rotten Tomatoes has
nearly 2,000 people on board with it
it's created by DC EU fanboys upset with
Disney which owns Marvel they they say
Disney rigged the Rotten Tomatoes scores
of movies like Star Wars the last Jedi
making it seem like they were getting
better reviews and they did they say
they like paid off critics so I guess
these these conspiracy theorists are
planning to take it out on a Black
Panthers audience score I guess yeah
take your revenge and I'm sure that's
not the only reason some of them are
really seen some hate on Black Panther
but I won't get into that we Rotten
Tomatoes basis of course it's tomato
meter score on a compilation of critics
review summarizing each review as
generally positive or generally negative
and kind of using that binary
combination to commute a percentage
fresh average score now the website has
said in a statement that there was no
foul play that happened with the last
Jedi and they said they're gonna take
steps to make sure it doesn't happen
with a black panther now obviously this
campaign is ridiculous and I don't think
it'll hurt Black Panther at all it's
just kind of like a symbolic protest
thing but I think we can agree that
Rotten Tomatoes is a terribly accurate
way to gauge how good a movie is it's
just crazy to assume that the site
itself is anti DC because they're just
basing everything on critics reviews yes
an aggregate yeah they can't write lean
anyway because they don't come up with
this course but looking at that though I
do guys see any possible bias in the way
the critics look at the this kind of
polarization the way they talk about
these movies well yes a thousand times
yes the idea is that a human being gives
you their subjective opinion and it is
translated to a score which
supposedly objective right like going to
the masses but people who build
well people choosing to be endeavor to
be a film critic obviously you know I
mean if we've done a little bit of like
our background research on like learning
what it takes to be a film critic things
like that it attracts a certain type of
person with certain type of standards so
there's an inherent bias in the idea of
being a film critic what you consider
good we've said it a thousand times but
that's why Dark Knight was not nominated
for Best Picture right it was just like
well no but you can't cuz it's a
superhero film so is there an errant
bias in terms of critics sure is that
new no and actually I think the fact
that they share the audience score is
brilliant I actually really love the
fact that there is a very different
score for for Star Wars because it kind
of just showed you like critics might
say it's a great film that doesn't mean
as a fan you're gonna be in love with it
it doesn't mean that it's the fan is any
more right than the critic either but
the fact that they've gone out of their
way to say like look audiences are mixed
about it critics like it I mean that's
usually when you go down the list of
Oscar contenders for Best Picture
there's usually one or two that have a
pretty low audience score actually and
it's usually the ones that make you fall
asleep yeah so I think yes it's biased
but they do their best that they can I
really like Rotten Tomatoes actually
mm-hmm and also to be fair sometimes
like there's gonna be some bad press
behind certain films and sometimes that
will influence people and and the way
Rotten Tomatoes like gauges it picks
keywords out of it it's not a person
sitting down for every single movie that
ever comes out and it's like oh this
one's positive it's actually just
looking for things and then it builds it
from there again the websites not being
biased it's just trying to come up with
the the streamlined version of trying to
like get this aggregate score no this is
the dump this is one of the dumbest
things I've ever heard in my entire life
it's so delusional to do this and I
don't know if I'm just shoe myself in
the foot with the audience that like
watches this hopefully you guys are the
cool ones that wouldn't ever support
something like this also yeah what do
you get movie yeah pick before ever
doing this protest do it for last Jenna
if you want to do that also give up on
last Jedi the movie already made its
billion dollars right
and there's no there's no nothing to
fight either I'm sorry this is the this
is so stupid yeah do this for Avengers
infinity war if you want to pick a movie
Black Panther means so much culturally
there's so many people that you need to
just back off and pick another thing you
fight about you know what other movie
made nearly a billion dollars is Justice
League through what critics think
clearly audiences around the world love
this movie
like it's not affecting whatever the
critics reviews are which I'll you know
I'll throw you the smallest bone
I don't think Justice League deserved a
forty percent I mean I granted that it's
again based on binary reviews if critics
were just lukewarm on it sometimes that
just counted as a negative review and
maybe that's not fair but I thought thor
ragnarok sure was a better movie it
scored like a ninety two percent around
tomatoes was it fifty two percentage
points better than Justice League maybe
not what does it matter they both end up
making roughly the same hundreds of
millions of dollars worldwide you're
picking these battles over the smallest
things that don't really matter they
still we why can't why not both why
can't we just have both these great
things that we're in the best time ever
to be a fan of comics and superheroes
because they're making every possible
adaptable story and they're bringing the
screen and they're giving it's a great
writers and directors and great actors
who want to do these things why do we
have to like why can't we just be
satisfied wasn't torn apart by critics
at all actually everyone across the
board love that movie so your argument
doesn't make any sense just as like had
mountains of bad press against it and
like whatever you think about that is a
different conversation we can have you
don't so talking to the person who made
this group and anyone who's joined it
you are not understanding how reality
works this is this is kind of pathetic
and you need to give up it might be a
troll I don't know if it's a troll great
ty you nailed it like that's a great
joke I really like it but if you were
actually supporting that genuinely
you're missing the point
yeah I mean but I think bad movie to
pick to fight against so yeah what was
it you said a couple weeks ago like
resolutions for 2018 just like what you
like and if you don't like something
just also you're humans you don't need
everyone to like the thing that you like
exactly that's not you like
awesome yeah great I'm happy for you and
go watch Black Panther because let's
[ __ ] live and watch another Batman movie
when it comes out I assume everyone
watching this will do these things
anyway these movies some very exciting
all right well let us know what you
think down in the comments remember but
this is new rockstars news so guys let's
move on and return back to ant-man in
the wasp ok everyone after new rockstars
broke down the trailer for ant-man in
the wasp recently upon re-watching it we
realized there were even more super
interesting details that it's the first
time so if you haven't already go back
and watch the breakdown but here are
four additional Easter eggs are you
ready yes okay well first early on
there's a shot of Pimm's new vessel
warming up in its lab and if you look to
the right side you can see a giant
Duracell battery now this is probably
being used as him as an energy source to
power his lab which is probably how he's
able to move it portably in that
rollaway building it's just battery
powered I have so many questions yeah
physics I think this movie I know would
never answer he doesn't have time for
that
like how can ant-man punch with the
force of a man but we can pick up a
building it doesn't make any sense if I
if I through that building if somebody
would it feel like a whole building
hitting you in the face
mm-hmm the old question mark what does
even feel like yeah next there are a lot
of shots of Scott and hope inside a Pym
technology equipment which can resize
with all the contents and passengers
inside of that van and some of you guys
pointed out to me that this could be the
MC used version of the ant van from the
comics it's customized van Scott Lang
mix for ant-man security solutions it
basically looks like a terminators to
our exterminators truck Terminator kind
of yeah
now for this next one I feel a little
dumb for missing this at first but when
Scott becomes the giant man version
himself and looms out of the bay over
the ferry looking down at sunny birch
birches clutching that miniature eyes
rolled away building that we saw Hanks
shrink down earlier I know it's a bit
obvious I just I guess that's what he's
after
you know PIMs entire lab building I mean
I guess if it's that small why not try
to steal the whole thing right and then
finally in the close-up of
hands as she revs her motorcycle you can
see a container with some gold colored
serum
now I'm thinking ghosts could be using
the serum to trigger her intangibility
phase shifting allowing her and perhaps
her bike to pass through surfaces and
objects during this high-speed chase now
yeah you guys are at some of these
details seem a little silly and
practical a blown up battery being used
as a generator a building with a
slide-out handle and wheels does this
stuff seem too goofy for you guys or
would you like to see it man
the sequel go more in this direction I
don't care make giant Pez is all I want
to eat a giant Pez I want to know what
that's like I just have brought it up
again just can't is it what it doesn't
make sense if like if you shrink
something the mass is still there okay
if the mass go somewhere else we'll
accept that then it's punched shouldn't
do anything right it should be the
effect of if an ant actual ant
was actually like yanking onion that
wouldn't do anything well how did they
explain in the first movie that like
they were made larger would have like
super strength but that really has to do
with like surface tension on a
miniaturised scale like ants can lift up
to something 30 times their body weight
and yeah so shouldn't the building weigh
is my building there or the idea that on
Futurama nibblers poop but here's the
question for you guys did he build a
giant retractable handle with giant
wheels and put those on the building or
did he build the building shrink it put
those in there make it big again and
then hide it I think he built the
miniaturised version first because if a
building is made of like drywall and
steel and all these like wooden things
in there if you were to just like cut
out part of it it's not like a cake that
you're gonna slice down in the middle
and like put like frosting inside it's
like the whole thing's gonna start to
fall apart if you start to like cut a
hole inside of it you're cutting away
like a huge chunk of the building I did
you might as well just build it small I
mean like an atrium like they just
the building they leave holes and then
he shrinks it and then he puts rods
through it and then he expands it again
I think it'd just be way easier to start
with a dollhouse and make it big there
you go I mean there's options here I
think he built it shrunk it put those in
there made it big again and then he just
was wake it's weighted if he built a
doll house II think there's like
subtlety to the desks in there and stuff
you think they're just like popsicle
sticks that are barely glued together
maybe the doors work like with like you
cannae tool you can put in fixtures and
furniture and doors after the fact I
think the main layout of it and the
different floors in the structural
integrity of it was made on a small
level and then later on he brought in
these are the questions and also what
happened to all glassware and rolling
chairs as soon as he picked that
building all right yeah even if you
secured it that's that you can't yeah
magnets these are the questions that
drive us well let us know what you think
in the comments below and again check
out our breakdown of all the other stuff
you might have missed in the trailer and
Ryan just subscribe the new rock stars
to stay up to date on all the stuff you
missed in your favorite Marvel movies
thanks everybody
but now it is time to move on to our new
rock stars news all right so you guys
tweeted us some questions I'm gonna fire
them at my co-host have to answer them
as quickly and without hesitation as
possible are you ready yes okay for Sam
since agents of shield has proven that
they don't leave many open threads how
long until we see VJ and nadir again
that's the Senators brother from season
four he says that I know it seems like
he died but according to this guy at the
end of the episode his dead body went
through terrigenesis at the bottom of
the lake yeah I'd say season five seems
pretty concrete I think when they come
back he could be in the second half of
this season or season six if they go to
season six um what is the most memorable
death so far in game
of thrones from a task for seconds
oberyn martell the jelly okay for me
true what movie franchise er series
would be your worst nightmare to do a
breakdown of for example if you had to
break down all 15,000 seasons the CSI
that would be pretty bad from wanna
switch a CEO and it might be fun to
break down I was gonna say the walking
dead Ivan I'd be like that'd be fun I
mean really procedurals that a Gunsmoke
I mean it seems like a real boring
Western that went on for like 40 seasons
yeah Jersey Shore yeah yeah well thank
you for your questions everybody make
sure to tweet us next week at new rock
stars look for our tweet about the
lightning round and respond to those so
get your tweets on the episode alright
next up let's take a look at what we got
in the entire time all right well next
up let's take a look at what we got in
the pipeline for videos coming out on
this channel in the next week guys on
Monday it's finally happening Disney and
Lucasfilm have announced that they will
be releasing a trailer for solo a Star
Wars story I don't know why it's taking
this long but here it is we're we might
see a 30-second trailer of it on Sunday
but on Good Morning America on Monday
they're gonna show the whole thing and
of course we're gonna jump right on it
we're gonna work through the night to
make sure you guys get a trailer
breakdown as soon as possible point out
everything you missed and talk about
what this movie is and as I mentioned
sunday is the big game that's all we're
allowed to say and it sounds like we'll
be seeing a few trailers for upcoming
properties actually Jurassic world
fallen Kingdom a second trailer for that
Westworld season 2 maybe a couple of
other trailers so keep an eye out for
trailer breakdowns on those big trailers
that drop during the big game and then
Sam's got a video as one I just shot a
Thor the first Thor from 2011 a
breakdown for it spoilers that movie
does not hold up very well but there are
a bunch of fun
Easter eggs and it's gonna be the next
installment of my MCU rewatch I'm very
excite Captain America First Avenger I'm
watching that this weekend doing a
breakdown very exciting yeah and we
definitely more in the pipeline for Game
of Thrones and Walking Dead as well so
for all of you fans of those shows keep
an eye out for those
but now comes the time for our 15-second
shout out where my imaginary friends and
I have 15 seconds to shout out blah gram
about anything we want Sam when I start
I'm gonna do - you can't stop me happy
just got its season finale they're gonna
give season two go watch that also Black
Lightning the show is mind-blowing Lee
awesome does it make you question the
quality of all the other CW shows yes it
does it's very good
for my 15 seconds out out I saw a clip
from jeopardy where the category round
was talking football and the three nerds
didn't answer a single one of them right
they just let it expire time expire I
mean these are simple ones I mean I'm
not the biggest football fan but the
first one was like what is an option the
option play what is a safe catch the
fair catch like it was a safe catch I'm
like yeah the reason I loved it is I
related with with these guys I'm like
that would probably be maybe well heat
for the last one he said because they
didn't getting them right he's like
let's just see the thousand dollar clue
just for the fun of it yeah kind of a
glad it's such a fun class remember that
all nerds can relate to cool and then
for my 15 second Chado I'm gonna shout
out our intern that we had here
Jaqueline shin she's a great internship
and as part of her internship project we
had her make a video in our style and
it's a actually a topic I'm really
excited about it's about disaster
artists and then it's who really is
Tommy Weis oh because it's true that we
actually have no idea what planet he's
from like what what he eats like where
to get money there's so much mystery
behind this guy and she dives into a
bunch of theories in that video and so
you can check it out on her channel and
also go follow her on Twitter it's at
shin Jan Nate
which is also her her youtube ham yeah
so check that video out and thank her
for helping us out yeah thank you
alright well finally let us return to
the trivia question
so just re distributing the cards here
and then I'll take and then you can take
mine okay so to remind everyone over
what it was in the first ant-man was the
name of the Pym technologies executive
whom Darren cross disgustingly murdered
by turning them into a I have trimmed
rankle MD the answer is Frank twin rank
so Frankel Frank because it's a title
drink'll makes you want to call it you
went to medical school don't don't just
throw it away the various judges so as
we mentioned before as the winner I will
do a goodbyes and you know I'll just do
some bit but we're also going to run
through our in other news headlines that
we didn't have time for I'm going to
read the other news headline and Sam as
a loser the trivia question dr. Tim
trimmed wrinkle you'll have to be trim
make a joke at the end of the
headline - you know like cleverly riff
on it that's great cuz trim did improv
in college so yeah undergrad or medical
school ryan Johnson said that he told
Adam driver to think about Anakin's
expression hidden christensen Anakin's
expression as he became Darth Vader and
Revenge of the Sith to inspire kylo
ren's emotion at the end of the last
Jedi I kind of wish they just showed him
that sand clip over and over again cuz
that's exactly what I thought kylo Ren
was like in that entire movie oszi was
rough and number two a survey showed
that 24% of British people know the
story of Game of Thrones better than
they know the story of the Nativity
[Music]
number three
study that analyzed the facial
structures of actors concluded that
Daniel Craig was the least attractive
James Bond he's the least interesting
one happy being the most boring except
for Casino Royale Skyfall I didn't see
it what I'm the Internet number four a
trailer for the Pokemon animated series
Sun and Moon showed the dangerous ultra
beast named buzz wall a mosquito like
Pokemon sucking the blood of a Snorlax
and horrifyingly deflating him what yeah
he had had it coming Bing Bing I'm sorry
that was rough I was I feel really
sweaty I think I don't wear black
tonight so you can't see all this number
five because you're so buzzed swole oh
there you go a bean paste
I didn't win pornography a production
company would rocket released a trailer
for the Rugrats porn parody called tug
rats which features retargeting a boner
ah that I didn't sorry you caught me off
guard and it goes to fill up a ding ding
gets the point for that one market on
the board I'm the loser for a reason
everybody trimmed rankle MD follow me on
Twitter Wow well who should I do I'm
gonna be Tim trimmed wrinkle trim
patience thank you for watching this
week's episode of new rock stars news oh
you you're terminally ill don't turn me
into a supply of goo please because I
want to thank our ghosts in Kuwait okay
so we got ice we got Phillip Melina guys
comment down below and tweet us here at
new rock stars like this video share it
around subscribed in New York search for
deep dives on all the stuff you love
guys see you next week trim on the show